bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france alors expliquez nous pourquoi
l'otan fait appel à l'armée française à
la frontière russe alors l'otan selon sa
perception au géopolitique qui est
largement alignés sur les intérêts
géopolitiques des états unis c'est de
considérer que l'europe est menacée à
l'est par la russie mais aussi au sud
est il ya une équivalence entre la
menace à l'est et au sud et dans le
cadre de l'otan évidemment les
perceptions de sécurité des différents
états membres sont différentes les pays
à l'aise sur tous les pays baltes la
pologne considère que c'est la menace
russe qui est la plus importante mais
des pays comme la france ou l'italie
considère que c'est la menace djihadiste
au sud qui est la plus importante est
ceci dit et cette décision alors pour
qu'on comprenne qu'elle est soutenue par
les pays membres de l'union européenne
majoritairement quelle est leur position
alors là la position de la france
d'abord c'est en fait d'essayer
d'attirer les pays les états membres de
l'otan vers ses propres priorités
géopolitiques qui sont au sud
et c'est pour claque ce pour cela que la
france déploie symboliquement des
troupes sur le flanc oriental dans une
approche de réassurance pour convoyer le
message aux pays d'europe centrale et
orientale que la france protège leur
sécurité à l'est pour en retour à voir
leur soutien au sahel
mais évidemment ce faisant la france
s'aligne sur la sur la la la priorité
géopolitique de l'otan qui évidemment
est aligné sur les intérêts anglo-saxons
et américains en particulier de
considérer que c'est la menace russe qui
est la plus importante et donc la france
prend le risque de créer des malentendus
avec la russie
parce qu'évidemment 7 ce déploiement
sera perçue comme une provocation alors
même que la france avait proposé une
nouvelle architecture européenne de de
sécurité pour négocier avec la russie et
en fin de compte la france comme la
plupart des pays européens auraient
intérêt à une alliance continentale
puisque l'europe est coincé entre ces
deux arts crise l'arc de crise au sud et
la de crise avec la russie à l'ess
évidemment il serait nécessaire de
surmonter cet arc de crise à l'est pour
coopérer avec les tous les pays
européens et la russie comprise mais
aussi les pays d'asie centrale pour
faire face à la menace au sud et pour
avancer dans cette négociation
évidemment ne serait préférable de ne
pas procéder à des provocations inutiles
alors pour la dmr kutina l'expansion de
l'otan est une menace pour les citoyens
russes à quel niveau est ce réellement
une relation vont alors il faut regarder
une carte en géopolitique il faut
regarder une carte pour voir les les
bases et les forces en présence et
effectivement après la chute de l'urss
tous les pays occidentaux avaient promis
à l'urss
et lorsque gorbatchev était encore
président de lurs et ensuite à la russie
de ne pas étendre l'otan et de ne pas
provoquer la russie est de dépasser cet
affrontement est ouest mais en fait ce
qui s'est passé c'est que les les l'otan
s'est élargi à l'est
et petit à petit les bases se sont
installés notamment en allemand dans les
différents pays de l'union européenne et
de l'otan en europe centrale orientale
jusqu'à la frontière russe et la russie
évidemment se sont poussés dans ces
terres continentales et lorsqu'on
regarde une carte aussi du monde
on voit bien que tout le dispositif des
bases américaines et
le bouclier antimissile procès d'un
encerclement de l'eurasie parce que
l'objectif finalement évidemment et
d'encercler l'eurasie avec la russie et
la chine
parce que les états unis veulent éviter
qu une puissance sur le continent
eurasien viennent défier leur pouvoir
mondial et les européens tant qu'il
s'aligne sur cette approche géopolitique
évidemment ne rompt pas d'autonomie
stratégique
merci beaucoup pour votre regard pierre
emmanuel thomas je rappelle que vous
êtes consultant en france géopolitique
fondateur d'euro continent